bien bonjour à toutes et à tous à tous
ceux que j'ai pas salué
j'ai le grand honneur et le grand
plaisir de devoir animer cette table
ronde sur un sujet majeur qui concerne
notre avenir nos enfants nos
petits-enfants
donc quelle politique fiscale pour
répondre à l'urgence climatique alors je
vais commencer par présenter rapidement
nos deux
intervenants l'un est très connu de nous
tous pierre aussi alors pierre la route
est à mes collègues au Parlement
européen nous sommes ensemble en
commission emploi et à faire sociale et
d'ailleurs nous travaillons aussi
ensemble sur des sujets liés à
l'innovation sociale comme la semaine de
quatre jours puisqu'on a on a déposé un
projet sur ce thème mais là pierre est
là en tant qu'economiste
nous parler de l'urgence climatique
puisqu'ici siège au conseil pour le
climat il a travaillé avec Michel Rocard
voilà il a un parcours bien connu et
très riche
et il connaît bien le sujet et je pense
qu'il va nous présenter des propositions
j'allais dire iconoclaste ce qui est
aussi le cas de mon cher ami Jean-Paul
Mattei qui a défrayé la chronique la
semaine dernière enfin cette semaine
avec ce rapport remis dont on a retenu
surtout une des propositions alors qu'il
y en avait d'autres sur le patrimoine et
au fond quelle taxation pourrait faire
pour accompagner une fois de plus cette
urgence climatique alors je me faisais
je vais être brève dans mon introduction
d'abord je suis pas une spécialiste des
questions fiscales plus des questions
sociales que des questions fiscales mais
je me faisais la réflexion ce matin je
la partageais avec Pierre que j'ent ce
matin qu'on nous reproche souvent au
niveau européen d'être lent dans
l'action et bien on a quand même été
capable d'être rapide et réactif quand
il y a eu la crise pandémique et la
covid puisqu'en quelques mois en 2020 on
a été capable de monter un plan de
relance pour sortir de la crise a quand
même 750 milliards d'euros
a complètement innovant très rapidement
en ammobilisé tout le monde sans doute
c'est parce que la notion d'urgence
apparaissait vraiment et je suis frappé
d'ailleurs qu'on parle plus du tout on a
l'impression que ça jamais existé qui a
pas eu cette crise covid le monde s'est
arrêté voilà on est reparti et au fond
sans doute ça va être le premier sujet
que que Pierre va adresser
est-ce qu'on a vraiment le sentiment
qu'à cette urgence climatique qui font
des moyens à la hauteur est-ce qu'on a
vraiment ce sentiment d'urgence j'en
suis pas si sûr même si on en parle même
si on voit des catastrophes tous les
étés
de plus en plus malgré tout peut-être
qu'elle nous parle pas autant que une
crise pandémique telle qu'on a vécu et
ça explique peut-être qu'on soit un peu
lent dans nos processus budgétaires et
au niveau de tout ce qu'on prévoit alors
il y a quand même eu des avances on a
l'accord au CDE qui a fait qu'on a quand
même eu pour la première fois une
taxation de 15% des multinationales de
leur profil c'est complètement aberrant
nous aurait dit ça il y a quelques
années on jamais on aurait pensé qu'on
serait arrivé à ça
plus des projets sur les ressources
propres qui sont des gros débats pour
nous au niveau du Parlement européen des
fonds qu'on a voté voilà donc ça
progresse mais est-ce qu'on a autant que
ça ce sentiment de l'urgence donc sans
plus attendre je vais céder la parole à
Pierre qui va nous dépeindre un petit
peu la situation déjà sur l'urgence
climatique merci merci Sylvie bonjour à
tous et à toutes ça fait trois ans que
j'étais pas venu à Guidel ça commence à
me manquer merci beaucoup et je crois
que tu poses une bonne question est-ce
qu'on a vraiment compris l'urgence
climatique je vais commencer par un
graphique je sais pas si la régie peut
faire un zoom là-dessus le powerpoint ne
marche pas c'est le nombre d'événements
climatiques extrêmes qui a déjà triplé
c'est une courbe qui vient des sociétés
d'assurance et je me suis un des
conseillé la Merkel qui m'a dit qu'il
est 20 minutes pour me recevoir puis
j'ai commencé avec ce graphique il m'a
gardé 1h30 finalement le nombre
d'événements climatiques extrêmes a déjà
triplé alors que le réchauffement est
seulement de 1,1 degré ma grand-mère
était bretonne à l'époque de ma
grand-mère il pleuvait tous les jours
l'été dernier la Bretagne a été
défigurée par des feux de forêts qu'on
n'avait jamais vu c'est partout il y a 6
ans la récolte de blé en France on n'a
pas du moins 30% sur la récolte de blé à
cause des inondations c'est très concret
heureusement que l'Ukraine la même année
avait fait une bonne récolte sinon on
aurait des tickets de rationnement cette
année c'est au contraire la sécheresse
vous souvenez tous au mois d'avril il y
avait déjà 70 départements en France au
mois d'avril qui était en état de
sécheresse où les paysans se disaient
qu'il n'auraient pas assez d'eau pour un
circuit normal donc être on est capable
de comprendre l'urgence qu'on est en
train de vivre il y a trois semaines
12000 morts en Libye 12000 morts en
quelques heures en Libye à cause d'une
tempête jamais vue parce que l'eau de la
Méditerranée est un niveau de chaleur
jamais vu l'été dernier c'est encore
Météo France était fait engueuler en
disant vous n'avez pas vu venir la
tempête qui a dévasté une petite partie
de la Corse là c'est en Libye 12000
morts et il y a aucun doute le World
Weezer attribution donc des
scientifiques qui disent est-ce que oui
ou non il y a un lien avec le
réchauffement climatique on dit que ce
qui s'est passé en Libye est bien lié au
réchauffement climatique et que le
réchauffement climatique qui réchauffe
les eaux de la Méditerranée de façon
considérable fait que ce genre de
catastrophe est 50 fois plus probable
qu'il y a 40 ans 50 fois plus probable
et avec une puissance augmentée de 50%.
donc là c'est la ville de Derna qui a
été détruite mais ça peut être Marseille
ou Toulon ou une autre ville voilà donc
on n'est pas à l'abri de notre vivant on
est tous les deux à Bruxelles une bonne
partie de notre temps et bien chaque
fois que je vais voir la direction
générale de l'énergie c'est très concret
il y a deux ans il y a eu 200 personnes
qui sont mortes dans les inondations la
fille de directrice générale de
l'énergie est morte elle est partie
encore en scout la vie est belle c'est
le début du mois de juillet la vie elle
part et puis il pleut il pleut il pleut
en quelques heures c'est l'horreur et
bien on ne reverra jamais plus vivante
j'en parle avec émotion parce que tout
le monde a quand on va à la direction
générale de l'énergie dit ça peut nous
toucher tous chacun de nous peut voir
son conjoint ses enfants sa tuer par un
dérèglement climatique donc est-ce qu'on
est capable de réagir la Banque mondiale
dit que si on ne fait rien on aura 140
millions de réfugiés climatiques d'ici
30 ans 140 millions essentiellement en
Afrique 90 millions d'hommes et de
femmes qui auront le choix entre crever
sur place ou traverser la Méditerranée
donc ça sert à rien de verser des larmes
de crocodile sur ce qui se passe à
Lampedusa on est déjà pas très bien
capable de les accueillir de façon
fraternelle mais qu'est-ce que si
l'Afrique se disloque si l'Afrique se
disloque à cause du réchauffement
climatique à cause du manque de
développement économique je voyais
l'autre jour Jean-Louis Borlo il y a 10
ans et proposer un grand plan pour
permettre l'accès de tous à
l'électricité il y en a qui ont ricané
mais aujourd'hui ce n'est pas capable en
même temps d'agir fortement en Europe et
d'agir avec l'Afrique notre notre
continent voisin si l'Afrique se
disloque réchauffement climatique et
manque de développement on va connaître
des le chaos de notre vivant de notre
vivant on va connaître des scènes
d'horreur deuxième point une fois qu'on
a dit la gravité il n'y a plus aucun
doute sur le diagnostic il y a une
époque où Claude Allègre des peut-être
que oui peut-être que non le CO2 mais il
y a eu un vote à l'unanimité de
l'Académie des Sciences y compris Claude
Allègre lui avait son chapeau après 6
mois de débat il n'y a plus aucun doute
aujourd'hui sur le fait que le
réchauffement climatique vient à 100% du
CO2 émis par la société humaine voilà
l'évolution du CO2 depuis 1000 ans
jamais jamais on regarde les carottes de
glace c'est comme ça qu'on le maîtrise
jamais le CO2 n'avait dépassé les 280
unités des scientifiques parlent le PPM
partis par million jamais il y avait eu
plus de 280 unités de CO2 et là on est
monté à 424 ça c'est la courbe depuis
1000 ans mais la courbe de 800 000 ans
j'ai fait un powerpoint comprend
peut-être envoyer à tous ceux et celles
qui participent c'est le plus agréable
c'est la courbe depuis du CO2 dans
l'atmosphère il y avait des oscillations
parce que la terre ne pas tourne pas de
façon parfaitement consciente autour du
soleil donc il y avait les oscillations
de température de CO2 mais jamais jamais
depuis 800000 ans on avait dépassé les
280 unités de CO2 aujourd'hui on a 144
en françois Bayrou il n'est pas là dans
une salle qu'en François est né on était
à 311 unités de CO2 311 on est à 424
donc il y avait un équilibre depuis
800000 ans il y avait des osciliations
mais en gros il y avait un équilibre
depuis 800000 ans et depuis un siècle on
a foutu en l'air cet équilibre alors où
est-ce qu'on en est tu l'as dit j'étais
membre du Haut Conseil pour le climat
avec Pascal Camphin on était deux que
Emmanuel Macron avait invité quand il
avait créé le Haut Conseil et Emmanuel
macronzek avait besoin de gens comme
nous pour le pousser les plus vite et la
première chose qu'a fait le Haut Conseil
pour le climat quand Emmanuel Macron
nous a installé c'est le bilan carbone
de la France et là je suis désolé de le
dire quand certains disent on a fait la
moitié du chemin c'est juste faux hélas
c'est faux cette courbe était dans le
journal Les Échos il y a un an
comprendre que si on tient compte que du
CO2 qui est mis en France c'est vrai
qu'on fait tous des efforts dans nos
entreprises dans nos vies de famille
donc le CO2 qui est sur le territoire
national a baissé de -25% quand certains
vous disent on a fait la moitié du
chemin on a baissé de 25 %, c'est vrai
pour le CO2 Émile sur le territoire
national mais la courbe qui vient du
ministère et qui est dans Les Echos
annexes au projet de loi de finances il
y a un an et demi disait si on tient
compte du CO2 qui vient de la Chine
parce qu'on a envoyé en Chine une bonne
partie de l'industrie polluante si on
tient compte de tous les produits qu'on
consomme et qui viennent de Chine et
bien le bilan CO2 de la France n'a pas
du tout diminué pas du tout diminué donc
on se rassure à bon compte en pensant
qu'on a fait la moitié du chemin que
c'était pas si compliqué il y a besoin
d'une vraie transformation il y a besoin
de comprendre l'urgence dernier point
sur le diagnostic pour dire que vraiment
quand Go terrestre est confiait sur
l'autoroute vers le chaos et la raison
depuis 1958 les Américains ont installé
à 3000 mètres d'altitude sur une
montagne pour être loin de toutes les
industries les pollution et tous les
jours des scientifiques américains
depuis 1958 mesure le CO2 dans
l'atmosphère dans les années 60 et 70 le
CO2 a augmenté de 0,8 unités plus 0,8
unités chaque année depuis 5 ans on est
à plus de virgule 4 aujourd'hui le CO2
dans l'atmosphère augmente 3 fois plus
vite 3 fois plus vite que dans les
années 60 ou 70 à cause des cercles
vicieux qui s'accélèrent le
réchauffement fait des feux de forêt et
les feux de forêts font de plus en plus
de CO2 qui vont accélérer le
réchauffement une année en Australie 400
morts dans les feux de forêts en
Australie 430 morts dans les feux de
forêts en Australie des gens comme vous
et moi qui étaient heureux on va
pique-niquer on va au boulot et on est
pris par le l'incendie donc cette année
c'est au Canada des surfaces colossales
qui ont brûlées c'est des dégâts pour
les forêts pour les biodiversité c'est
du CO2 donc tous ceux qui pensent que
on va un peu lentement mais on va dans
le bon sens non on ne va pas du tout
dans le bon sens malgré la cop21 la
cop22 la cop23 la COP Kea le CO2 dans
l'atmosphère augmente aujourd'hui trois
fois plus vite que des années 60 et 70
donc il faut changer de braquet et une
fois qu'on a compris l'urgence y compris
dans tous les milieux une des raisons de
fois où j'étais venu en Bretagne c'était
invité pour l'ensemble des jeunes
agriculteurs la brancheuse jeune de la
FNSEA qui disait aujourd'hui plus aucun
paysan ne conteste le réchauffement
climatique il m'avait invité pour le
grand débat de l'après-midi que peut
faire l'Europe pour gagner la bataille
du climat certains vous disent qu'il y a
des Français qui n'ont pas encore
compris l'urgence faut pas y aller trop
vite et bien le grand débat de terre de
gym il y a 4 ans à Fougères 5 ans à
Fougères c'était et le chef des jeunes
agriculteurs disaient il y a 10 ans on
était tous climato-sceptiques Claude
Allègre était notre héros et les écolos
nous casser les pieds aujourd'hui il n'y
a plus aucun paysan climatrice la
question est d'avoir comment est-ce
qu'on nous aide financièrement on a
invité monsieur la route Hureau qui
avait Jean jauzel porte des solutions
donc les solutions Jean-Paul on parlera
très très bien j'ai encore quelques
minutes pour dire au niveau européen
c'est pas mes propositions qu'est-ce que
propose le Parlement européen il y a ici
des collègues Marie-Pierre ou d'autres
ou Valéry on travaille on a listé on a
entendu les gilets jaunes on a entendu
les gilets jaunes c'est pas ceux qui
gagnent 1000 ou 2000 par mois qui
doivent être taxés et donc il y a 3 ans
on a fait un rapport je te l'enverrai
Jean-Paul je les ai envoyé par mail mais
tu as peut-être pas eu le temps de
regarder avec toutes les ressources
propres pour trouver des aides pour
chaque petite entreprise pour chaque
artisan pour chaque famille une vraie
rénovation thermique c'est 40 000 euros
40000 euros on va pas demander à chaque
famille de trouver 40 000 euros donc il
faut qu'on trouve des aides dans mon
coin des Pyrénées il faut en même temps
des transports en commun il y a aucun
transport en commun et la mairie doit
trouver du fric pour isoler la maison de
retraite la mairie la salle municipale
donc il faut des subventions donc le
parement européen proposait 6 solutions
une taxe carbone frontière une taxe
digitale une taxe tout ça tout ça est
bien mais c'est à chaque fois entre 4 et
5 milliards et Biden n'en veut pas c'est
entre 4 et 8 milliards mais on peut pas
le faire à cause de l'OMC et donc la
meilleure solution de tout ce que
proposait le Parlement c'est une taxe
sur les transactions financière c'est
une idée très simple tout le monde paye
de la TVA quand j'ai acheté mon
téléphone j'ai payé 20% de TVA 20% et
même les plus pauvres ceux qui dorment
dans la rue quand ils ont trouvé un peu
d'argent ils vont s'acheter de quoi
manger ils payent une TVA à 5,5 %. tout
le monde dans tous nos pays paye au
moins 5,5 de TVA mais aujourd'hui sur
les marchés financiers c'est
0,0,0 la TVA sur les marchés financiers
donc depuis 2011 Monsieur Barroso qui
sait pas l'extrême gauche il depuis il
est parti chez Goldman Sachs depuis 2011
la Commission Barroso proposait une
petite taxe de 0,1% sur les marchés
financiers c'est tout petit c'est 0,1
mais à la fin d'année on a 60 milliards
d'euros et donc l'ensemble du Parlement
européen demande à part l'extrême droite
tous les groupes soutiennent ça même 92%
des députés de la droite allemande le
George voyeur celui-là avant d'alleronne
qui était content de voir que ça fait
vraiment l'unanimité même 92% des
députés CD ou CSSU ont voté et là c'est
que la France qui bloque je vais pas
être long on a la lettre du ministre
autrichien des finances bien notre
Blumel je pourrais aller dans le
powerpoint d'avoir donc la droite
conservatrice autrichienne qui dit il
faut relancer la négociation mais c'est
la France qui bloque parce que
aujourd'hui la France dit qu'elle veut
plus de ressources pour l'Europe pour
rembourser une génération et pour le
climat mais aujourd'hui c'est marqué
noir sur blanc la France défend un
projet ou 99 % des volumes ne sont pas
taxés il existe déjà une petite TTF en
France créée par Sarkozy viol Hollande
elle ne concerne que 1% des transactions
chaque jour elle fonctionne elle a
provoqué aucune évasion l'an dernier
elle a même rapporté 1,6 milliards la
taxe sur les transactions qui existent
en France ne concerne que 1% des volumes
mais n'a provoqué aucun dégât et même en
étant que sur 1% des volumes chaque jour
elle a rapporté 1,6 milliard à la fin
d'année donc il y a pas besoin d'être un
prix Nobel pour se dire que si au lieu
d'être sur 1% des volumes si elle est
sur toutes les transactions comme le
demande le Parlement elle pourrait
rapporter beaucoup plus donc il y a
cette solution et deuxième idée et donc
ça permettrait d'avoir des aides moi mon
but c'est pas qu'on est une taxe quand
je me lève le matin je me dis pas ouais
je veux créer une taxe moi mon but c'est
que tout soit celle qui fera une
thermique savent sache qu'il y a une
aide efficace qui est durable parce
qu'aujourd'hui les règles changent sous
les 6 mois c'est insupportable pour les
gens du bâtiment et que si vous faites
une rénovation il y a des gens
compétents pour faire les travaux et que
vous aurez une aide entre l'aide de
l'Europe et l'aide qui existe en France
vous aurez une aide qui divise par 4 ou
par 5 le coût de la rénovation thermique
et si on est sûr que pendant 20 ans on a
des aides qui divisent par 4 ou par 5 le
coût de la rénovation thermique le
secteur du bâtiment peut recruter du
monde et on peut accélérer là-dessus
dernière idée et accessoirement en
termes de pouvoir d'achat je voyais
l'autre jour à monsieur qui a isolé sa
maison il gagne 800 euros chaque année
sur ses dépenses de chauffage il dit on
vit mieux on a moins chaud l'été moins
froid l'hiver et je gagne pour ma
famille 800 euros de pouvoir d'achat
chaque année dernière idée c'est une
idée que porter déjà Jacques Delors il y
a très longtemps c'est lutter contre la
concurrence fiscale Alain lamassour me
dit que déjà quand elle a été Jean-Louis
Bourlens avant j'étais rapporteur
général du budget il y a deux ans mais
la dernière fois c'était Jean-Louis
brolande il y a là la Massour était
président de la commission des budgets
ils me disent tous évidemment on est
d'accord quand j'étais petit l'IMP que
les sociétés l'impôt sur les sociétés
étaient à 50%. 50%. et puis depuis que
l'Angleterre est rentré c'est chaque
année qu'on baisse un peu l'impôt pour
faire comme les voisins on est tombé à
19%. aujourd'hui l'impôt sur les
sociétés est à 19%. alors que aux
États-Unis je sais pas je vais la courbe
de Roosevelt jusqu'à Trump l'impôt n'est
jamais tombé en tout de 38 %. donc c'est
le monde à l'envers 38% aux États-Unis
19% en Europe et déjà quand elle a la
masseur il y a 20 ans ou Jean-Louis
brolan j'étais au Parlement Jacques
Delors tout le monde disait il faut un
impôt européen pas sur les pas sur les
artisans mais sur les grandes
entreprises et on pourrait avoir un
impôt de 5% même avec un impôt de 5% au
niveau européen sur les bénéfices
d'entreprises on resterait en dessous du
niveau des États-Unis donc il y a aucun
problème de compétitivité même avant
d'être député en effet un événement il y
avait Alain Juppé il y avait Laurence
Parisot qui me disait qu'ils étaient
d'accord pour un impôt de 5% sur les
bénéfices donc je crois je vais laisser
l'apport à la Jean-Paul il y a plein de
solutions mais il y a une urgence à
trouver de l'argent et rien qu'en France
se plant climat avec des vrais
financements pour créer 9 donc est-ce
qu'on a compris l'urgence climatique
est-ce qu'on a compris le fait que
rénover faire la rénovation thermique
faire des transports en commun c'est bon
Pôle emploi sur tous nos territoires on
a le soutien de tous les mers ruraux de
France qu'en a lancé cette initiative
avec Jean jaugeait on avait tous les
méruaux qui nous soutiennent et ça
m'énerve un peu entre nous Clément bonne
qui était ministre des affaires
européennes m'appeler tous les deux mois
dans je ne comprends pas pourquoi Bruno
Le Maire Bloch je ne comprends pas
j'envoie un message à Bruno pour qu'il
te reçoive il faut que Bruno bouge donc
peut-être qu'il y a des élus MoDem ici
qui peuvent nous aider pour dire Bruno
Le Maire oui il faut bouger la France et
le seul pays qui bloque la France est
aujourd'hui le seul pays qui bloque la
coopération renforcée sur la taxe
transaction financière merci
bon merci Pierre
merci c'est pas évident de traiter un
sujet aussi vaste en très peu de temps
donc merci d'avoir fait cet effort bon
vous avez compris on est tout de suite
sur des sujets très sensibles
en France on est quand même
champion des impôts de la taxation on
est quand même le second pays je crois
au monde sur les marchés financiers a
créé
une taxe sur les rachats d'actions
j'ajoute que nous le repens ensemble et
donc s'imbri New York et New York on
soutient aussi on est c'est aussi dans
notre stratégie on soutient ce projet de
taxe sur les transactions financières
qui nous semblent effectivement être une
solution pour l'avenir et pour une fois
de plus vraiment accompagné avoir les
moyens d'accompagner cette urgence
climatique sans toucher les particuliers
et accroître les impôts des particuliers
comme vous l'entendrez parfois de la
part notamment de l'extrême droite qui
dès qu'on parle de ressources propres au
début de jeu européen qu'il faut
accroître dit ah vous voyez on va
augmenter des impôts voilà encore ce qui
se prépare ce qu'il faut c'est tout de
suite compliqué quand on parle de ces
sujets alors Jean-Paul va pouvoir
prendre le relais et nous expliquer
notamment une des propositions car tenu
la tension entre autres
oui merci merci de ce débat merci à
Pierre
de nous angoisser mais nous angoisser
positivement
par rapport à l'avenir de la planète
j'ai eu l'occasion donc avec un collègue
communiste dans le cas d'une mission
dans le cas de la commission des
finances de faire un rapport sur la
fiscalité du patrimoine mais ça fait 7
ou 8 mois qu'on en parle et il se trouve
que
la recommandation qui ressort c'est une
proposition une réflexion sur un ISF
vers on va dire mais au niveau européen
il y a 27 recommandations même si dans
mes propos introductifs sous un rapport
qui qui met en évidence une forme
d'inégalité d'accroissement des
richesses et
une très grande richesse et c'est pas du
tout une critique c'est un constat
pour le dernier des cils avec
l'accumulation de
fortune économique peut-être utile aussi
pour le développement
et ressorti cette obligation
d'une réflexion sur l'environnement et
sur le futur de notre planète comment
mettre à contribution
je dirais tout le monde et que tout le
monde assume ses responsabilités sur
l'avenir de notre planète on a un
problème et sur la fiscalité c'est le
problème de en quelque sorte de la
concurrence fiscale entre les États et
le fait que si pour ça qu'on le
préconise au niveau européen si on le
fait que pour la France
on va comme je dis on se tire une balle
dans le pied
on va encore dire il y a que les
Français sur d'ailleurs les prélèvements
obligatoires en France moi j'ai pour
habitude de dire oui on peut peut-être
réfléchir dans l'enveloppe comme on peut
répartir et puis il faut voir les
services qu'on a en face même si on dit
que les services sont pas excellents
mais on a quand même des services en
France dans notre pays par rapport à
d'autres pays mais la question qui se
pose sur un ISF c'est la taxation du
stock par rapport au flux et c'est vrai
que
politiquement et même économiquement
taxer le stock c'est à dire l'impôt sur
la fortune peut s'interroger et je pense
que taxer les flux me semble beaucoup
plus acceptable on a tendance à être
c'est une évidence que je vais dire on
le consentement à l'impôt et plus facile
lorsqu'on a la trésorerie
que quand on l'a pas donc je pense qu'il
faut qu'on ait une réflexion globale sur
ce sujet on peut pas dire que le
gouvernement ne fait rien en matière
d'environnement dans le budget dans le
loi de finance il y a des tentatives et
il y a quand même des budgets qui sont
quand même affectés pour le
développement environnemental il y a
également l'impôt minimal des sociétés
de 15% qui est quand même une révolution
importante puisque
on leur aurait souhaité 21% mais on est
à 15 mais c'est vrai que l'obligation
est l'engagement c'est faire contribuer
ceux qui peuvent
sans réflexion sur la sanction l'impôt
c'est pas c'est pas une peine l'impôt
c'est un consentement c'est une le
consentement à l'impôt est excessivement
important et c'est de participer je
dirais à la vie de la société à la vie
notre planète après les lois de finances
parce qu'on aurait pu d'ailleurs
intitulé quelle politique fiscale et
politique de financement parce que c'est
le financement à long terme aussi de ces
de ces opérations on peut à mon sens des
investissements pour l'environnement qui
améliore rapidement l'état de la planète
ça peut se financer sur de nombreuses
années parce que j'ai l'économie
immédiate et je réfléchis et je peux
financer à long terme on le voit bien
d'ailleurs dans le plan de relance et
notamment la partie de l'État qui a eu
un budget près de presque 3 milliards
sur les bâtiments d'administes publics
chaque fois moi je préside je préside
encore le conseil immobilier de l'État
on essaie de réflexion est-ce que votre
financement est à long terme est-ce que
ça correspond à des économies d'énergie
et autres ensuite
la politique fiscale sont donc ces lois
de finances on critique souvent je
dirais les niches fiscales mais je dis
avec un petit sourire moi je sens niche
fiscal il n'y a pas de loi de finance
par définition une loi de finances doit
essayer d'orienter l'épargner français
dans telle et le secteur et Pierre tu
évoqué tout à l'heure le logement
au niveau moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on
ait une réflexion comment on favorise
l'investissement dans le logement
vertueux parce qu'on va on va on les
faces à une crise du logement et
accompagner on a d'ailleurs moi j'avais
déposé l'année dernière un amendement
qui prévoyait que quelqu'un qui loue un
bien
à titre de résidence principale avec un
loyer encadré et avec le respect de
l'environnement surtout des critères DPE
ABCD maximum puisse bénéficier d'une
option à flatta c'est à dire qu'on peut
à la fois
je dirais avoir des ressources
complémentaires mais il faut toujours
faire très attention parce que on est
sur une ligne de crête en disant si je
j'augmente les impôts je peux réduire la
base et donc trop d'impôts tu l'imposes
donc il faut faire attention parce que
ça reste toujours une ressource
dynamique et ensuite se dire comment je
réorienter par des Français dans de
l'investissement vertueux et notamment
de la transition énergétique et
il y a une réflexion par exemple sur la
prime rénove moi je je dis que la prime
rénov c'est un outil un peu complexe qui
a du mal à se mettre en place je sais
que nos collègues socialistes avaient eu
un texte qui prévoyait de faire une
avance en quelque sorte par l'état d'une
somme de 50000 euros et qui se
rembourseraient au moment de la vente du
bien c'était je trouve un moyen assez
intelligent de d'accélérer le phénomène
et de trouver un moyen ensuite de REM
cette avance mais qui permet de faire
des économies immédiatement d'être bon
pour la planète donc l'outil fiscal
c'était la fois orienter l'épargne c'est
certes une recherche de financement et
de ressources et à mon avis il faut que
ça soit sur les flux et je crois que
c'est au politique de décider de la
fiscalité il y a quelque chose qui me
m'interpelle et c'est le système des
fondations du mécénat et autres je dis
il faut faire très attention avec ça je
ne suis pas contre le mécénat bien au
contraire mais c'est c'est pas
l'entrepreneur de choisir la fiscalité
ou le je dirais l'utilisation de l'impôt
qui doit faire c'est à mon sens
politique de proposer et de regarder
comment on peut l'orienter ensuite il
faut créer des outils à la fois qui
favorisent à la fois qui contraignent
mais je sais très bien les limites de la
contrainte et qui soit dans
l'acceptabilité de cette nouvelle
fiscalité donc l'exercice est compliqué
je vois que le taux se termine
l'exercice est
compliqué on doit se servir de l'outil
fiscal mais attention effectivement il
faut pas que on crée un manque
d'attractivité pour le territoire mais
moi personnellement je pense que c'est
plus facile de travailler sur les flux
que ce que sur les stocks et donc d'où
l'idée de cette taxe sur l'impôt société
oui pourquoi pas mais là aussi il faut
qu'on ait une vision européenne des
choses et je suis content d'entendre que
au niveau européen il y a cette prise de
conscience nous avec notre vision très
française on a l'impression que les
blocages sont multiples la règle de
l'unanimité en matière de l'Europe pour
les décisions modifications fiscales il
faut que ça évolue et qu'on puisse y
travailler en toute responsabilité mais
je crois que moi le constat que j'ai
l'environnement et certainement notre
boussole actuellement pour le bien de la
planète et d'ailleurs si les gros
contribuables hésitent qu'il fasse
attention parce que demain leur entre
guillemets patrimoine peut être très
abîmée par les conséquences
environnementales mais je crois qu'il
faut rester sur le côté humain et rendre
la fiscalité acceptable la cibler et je
crois que il faut que on arrive à faire
la pédagogie sur le consentement l'impôt
parce que c'est utile non seulement pour
pour
nos concitoyens mais aussi c'est très
utile pour l'avenir de la planète
merci Jean-Paul mais je crois que c'est
une belle conclusion merci à tous les
deux on voit qu'il y a des points de
convergence et que on ne pourra pas se
passer du niveau européen pour agir
c'est absolument indispensable et
stratégique merci pour la qualité de nos
échanges en peu de temps sur un très
gros sujet
on ne peut même pas avoir d'échanges
avec la salle j'ai pas vu de questions
voilà dans des questions qui remontent
mais
sur
on peut pas
gouvernance mondiale elle existe oui
c'est l'OCDE de certaines manières quand
même
je crois que malheureusement je peux
prendre une minute de réponse
une minute c'est tout bon alors
un niveau mondial et Jean-Paul et
Sylviane en parler il y a eu un accord
pour un taux minimum de 15% de l'impôt
sur les sociétés on espérait 21% Joe
Biden avait dit dans tous nos pays on a
besoin d'argent on va mettre 21 % on a
eu un accord à 15 et là je suis désolé
mais la France n'était pas parmi ceux
qui poussaient pour aller plus hauts la
France pendant un mois a dit 12% il faut
un taux commun mais 12% ce serait bien
donc c'est un peu dommage que la France
n'est pas plaider pour une autre
solution plus ambitieuse donc il y a des
fois où c'est bien très bien très
important de faire un niveau mondial
mais il y a des fois où les américains
ils y vont Joe Biden le petit vieux qui
sort on nous a expliqué que c'est un
petit vieux qui dormait il a mis 2000
milliards depuis qu'il au pouvoir 2000
milliards en trois plans un plan pour
les infrastructures un plan pour les
microprocesseurs un plan pour lutter
contre l'inflation 2000 milliards on se
demande si l'Europe va décrocher mais
aux Etats-Unis ils y vont à la hache
pour les subventions et pour financer ça
sans avoir plus de dettes il fait une
taxe sur les rachats d'actions il a créé
la taxe des rachats d'actions à 1% les
bourses les bourses les banques en
grenier pendant une semaine mais
finalement c'est très bien passé il a
créé un pour cent et maintenant il veut
la mettre à 4 % et ça fonctionne il veut
faire une taxe sur les milliardaires non
pas les gens qui ont 500 000 dollars de
côté n'ont pas ceux qui ont une belle
maison à un million de dollars mais Joe
Biden veut une taxe sur les
milliardaires et ceux qui ont plus de
100 millions de capital ceux qui ont
plus de 100 millions de capital ils vont
pas en mourir si on leur demande un
petit effort et par contre si on
investit dans les infrastructures tout
le monde va y gagner Jean-Paul
non mais on a un débat actuellement sur
le système des rachat d'action les
États-Unis le pratiquent avec une taxe
de 1% il parle même de la faire
peut-être passer à 4 moi on répond dans
le débat
partage de la valeur non il faut que ça
soit une taxe qui permet d'alimenter un
budget voilà donc on n'est pas forcément
sur
partager la valeur c'est bien mais ça
concerne d'abord toujours le même
entreprise et il faut que cette taxe
puisse alimenter un budget un budget
général après c'est excessivement
compliqué de faire l'uniformiser notre
fiscalité mondiale parce que les régies
par plus de 100 presque 130 conventions
fiscale internationale c'est très
compliqué donc il faut qu'il y ait un
vrai pouvoir politique qu'il faut qu'on
chemine pas à pas je crois que l'Europe
a un rôle majeur à jouer d'exemplaires
par rapport à ça et je pense que le
futur élections vont être un débat très
intéressant sur ces questions et on voit
bien le stress mais le stress positif de
l'urgence climatique qui nous oblige par
rapport à tout ça voilà cette dépense
d'aujourd'hui est en fait une économie
pour demain
conclusion merci Jean-Paul
[Applaudissements]